war die junge erde mal eine reine wasser
planet also eine welt ganz ohne größeren
landmassen fachleute haben jetzt
hinweise darauf gefunden wie die erde
vor rund 3,2 milliarden jahren
ausgesehen haben könnte diese
erkenntnisse könnten auch endlich die
frage klären wie und wo das leben seinen
anfang nahm denn dann gibt es nur eine
möglichkeit kriegs und science fiction
gibt täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
die erste erdkruste hat sich wohl vor
rund vier milliarden jahren gebildet
nach ansicht von fachleuten müsste die
erde zu diesem zeitpunkt in etwa so weit
abgekühlt gewesen sein dass dieser
vorgang möglich wurde dann entstand das
urmeer und zwar zum einen durch sehr
extreme regenfälle und zum anderen durch
einschläge durch die wasser importiert
wurde ein großes rätsel für die fachwelt
aber ist die entstehung der ersten
kontinente manche untersuchungen legen
nahe dass die ersten landmassen schon
früh aufgetaucht sein könnten andere
studien gehen davon aus dass dies erst
vor rund 2,4 milliarden jahren passieren
da ein us forschungsteam ist der
entstehung der kontinente jetzt
nachgegangen
dazu nahmen die fachleute gesteinsproben
aus dem australischen pilbara kraton ins
visier
diese zählen als älteste christen
gesteine der erde dieses gestein bildet
eine art zeitkapsel denn es hat quasi
die geschichte der ozeane in sich
konserviert genau genommen ging es den
forschenden um die sogenannten isotopen
werte entscheidend hierbei das
verhältnis der beiden sauerstoff isotope
u16 und u18 isotope sind atome des
gleichen elements aber mit
unterschiedlichen anzahl von neutronen
im atomkern denn das lässt äußerst
spannende rückschlüsse zu unter anderem
bezüglich der ablagerungen oder
verwitterung von sedimenten und außerdem
auch zu den temperaturen der alten
ozeane in der vergangenheit dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam wasser mit
niedrigerer temperatur enthält eine
höhere menge an sauerstoff 16 als
sauerstoff 18 und umgekehrt
es gibt keine proben von richtig alte
meerwasser aber wir haben eine kleine
die mit dem damaligen meerwasser
interagieren und diese interaktion
konserviert haben das ergebnis der
fachleute war eindeutig denn es wurde
ein überschuss des schweren sauerstoff
isotops o 18 festgestellt im vergleich
zum heutigen meerwasser
das urzeitliche meerwasser wie es also
einen u18 überschuss von rund 3,3
promille gegenüber heutigen meerwasser
auf das spricht laut der aktuellen
studie für einen rein ozeanischen wasser
und sauerstoff kreislauf fehlten damals
möglicherweise also biochemische
prozesse die vor allem das schwere
sauerstoff isotope in die forschung
gingen diesem rätsel genauer auf die
spur und zwar mit hilfe verschiedener
modelle die szenarien legen nahe dass
vor rund 3,2 milliarden jahren wohl noch
keine ausgedehnten landflächen auf der
frühen erde zu finden waren somit
fehlten also auch entsprechende prozesse
wie beispielsweise die verwitterung
genauso wenig gab es damals wohl ton
haltige böden die das schwere sauerstoff
isotope ebenfalls bin diese erkenntnisse
lassen die forschenden zu dem ergebnis
kommen dass die folie erde eine
wasserwelt gewesen sein muss vor rund
3,2 milliarden jahren also gab es der
aktuellen studie zufolge also noch keine
größeren landmassen das bereits kleinere
mini kontinente teilweise aus der
wasseroberfläche herausschauten kann
sich das forschungsteam dagegen gut
vorstellen dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen studie
das bedeutet nicht dass der planet
notwendigerweise völlig wasser bedeckt
war
wie etwa die saturn und jupiter monde
enceladus oder europa wenn sie näher an
der sonne werde aber die erde scheint
sehr viel besser gewesen zu sein als sie
heute ist offen bleibt aber noch wann
tatsächlich die ersten kontinente
entstanden sind das sollen weitere
analysen der nächst jüngeren
gesteinsformationen zeigen
mit hilfe dieser art von forschung
kommen wir auch der frage aller fragen
immer weiter auf die spur denn solche
szenarien könnten endlich zeigen wo
genau das leben seinen anfang nahm in
den tiefen salziger mehrere oder aber in
süßwasser auf dem land dazu sagt
bossnapping einer der beteiligten
forscher
wenn die erde eine reine wasserwelt war
die vom ozean bedeckt war standen
trockenen nischen schlicht wirklich zur
verfügung dann kann das leben also nur
im salzwasser entstanden sein
plattentektonik spektrum erklärt da gibt
es mehr infos zur entstehung der
kontinente also anklicken anschauen und
spektrum video abonnieren sehr cooler
kanal des führenden deutschen
wissenschaftsmagazins in unserem
wissenschafts netzwerkes 1054 also
pflicht aber würde ich mal sagen bis
dann bleibt dran